In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for September 9, on which we commemorate, the memory of
the two hundred God-bearing fathers gathered at Ephesus in the year 431 for the third holy
ecumenical council that inathamantized the impious news stories.
The Emperor Thodosios II called Nestorius from Antioch, where he was highly regarded as
a godly and able orator, and raised him to the patriarchal dignity of the imperial city
in the year 428.
At first, Nestorius appeared as a firm defender of Christian morals and a zealous opponent
of the Aryans and Pelagians, but soon he began to teach that Christ does not unite perfectly
in himself, the divine nature and human nature, but is simply a divinized man, and therefore
the all-holy virgin cannot be called Thodos, that is to say, Mother of God.
It was largely due to the apostolic zeal and inspired writings of Saint Cyril of Alexandria
that the holy fathers led by him rejected this heresy and confirmed the faith of the first
two councils.
They thus clearly proclaimed that the Lord Jesus Christ has truly assumed human nature in
its fullness, so as to open to us all the possibility of a true union with his divine nature.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.